[Music]  background I think back to like being in  the playground at school you know I  guess when I was about 10 or 11 Kim  Basinger was named you used for like a  hot woman everything oh yeah I can [ __ ]  you know I'd be on just like physically  beautiful she still is  she's done incredible work in the past  you know I'm a big fan of her work Kim  was oh she was so gracious and so classy  but she was a pleasure to work with and  and to have her on set and she plays  Christian's ex-lover I think is the  kindest way you could describe her and  she plays for her very well she really  embraced Elena and throat Jamie Dornan  as well I remember her saying oh my god  can just just just kiss me  yeah so that was kind of funny  [Music]